buckle up welcome to Hannity explosive
new breaking developments exposing the
deep state we will get to all of this
momentarily complicated but simple on
the other hand Glenn Beck is here
tonight he's gonna weigh in on the dire
dangers of socialism and how it's real
but we begin with the presidential
campaign season in the Democratic Party
it is now off to a disastrous pathetic
start socialism oppressive taxes open
borders oh and during and post birth
abortion advocated by some they have now
become hot issues in a party that has
become even more radical and per usual
the mainstream media they are providing
the cover the support for these
candidates their extreme ideas very
shady past every step of the way we'll
investigate all of this and that is the
subject of tonight's Hannity watch on
the radical socialist 20/20 Democrats
right now at this hour
over a dozen presidential hopefuls have
already thrown their hats in the ring
many more are expected to declare before
the year's end and late last week former
failed senatorial candidate robert
Francis O'Rourke otherwise known as bado
bozo O'Rourke he announced his candidacy
the mainstream media they do what they
always do they fell in love with bado
Robert Francis take a look extremely
attentive he's just an extraordinary guy
he has a vibrancy a youthfulness to him
he has a message which is largely
cheerful he had a way of speaking
inspirationally but also really
seriously laying out the stakes what he
has to start with is a charisma that you
just can't manufacture
the Kennedy wins who's got the Sun in
his face who looks like sunny optimistic
not the endure bureaucrat sitting at
some desk somewhere seeing him is like
it's like a Jesus Christ Superstar
seeing this guy in front of people he's
got that celebrity aura about him and in
that moment he was owning that do you
feel like it kind of having deja vu here
it's almost like we've seen this kind of
cheerleading from these supposedly
unbiased mainstream media before we did
they were in love with Barack Obama and
just to remind you well we went into our
archives take a look
you can see it in the crown it's
thrilled
how they surge to it you are looking at
an American political phenomena you know
you are the equivalent of a rock star on
the bus ride along the snowy road to
Lebanon New Hampshire I showed him this
week's Newsweek hot off the presses how
does this feel of all the honors that
have come your way the feeling most
people get when they hear a Barack Obama
speech Mike I felt this photo going up
my leg I don't have that too often
steady no seriously it's a dramatic
event I like to say that in some ways
Barack Obama is the first president
since George Washington to be taking a
step down into the Oval Office throws up
the leg and everything now this love
affair persistent for eight long years
and Beyond and it was so bad this
program was one of the very few only
shows to actually do the real vetting of
future President of the United States
Barack Obama remember on this program we
showed you Obama's ties to the radical
unrepentant Weather Underground domestic
terrorist Bill Ayers and Bernardine
Dohrn it was right here on this show we
revealed the true nature of Obama's
longtime pastor of 20 plus years
Jeremiah Wright and the Church of Gd
America rooted in Black Liberation
Theology which we explained to you and
Frank Marshall Davis and acorn and
Olinsky and community organizing and now
it is once again I guess up to us to vet
the 2020 candidates which we promise we
will be doing nightly remember our
predictions of a failed Obama presidency
rooted in these radical views turned out
to be more accurate than we would have
ever wished for for our country if the
media done their job America might have
avoided that disaster they were Obama's
cheerleaders every single day even on
the ridiculous 150 billion dollar
Iranian deal well we can see history is
now repeating itself take for example
the latest controversy surrounding
Reuters and robert Francis o Rourke on
Friday we learned that one of their
reporters Reuters sat for almost two
on an embarrassing story about
O'Rourke's time as a renegade online
hacker until after his hotly contested
Senate race with Senator Ted Cruz had
the story sat on it in fact the reporter
named joseph menn entered into an
agreement with bado bozo to delay his
damning story so long as the Roarke
granted him the interview now if it
seems like the mainstream media
Democrats work together to win elections
as one team that is because they
actually do so-called journalists like
joseph menn shielding democrats from
embarrassment by spiking or delaying
certain reports all while sticking it to
President Trump every second every
minute every hour of every day no matter
how shaky the story how weak the
sourcing if any sourcing take for
example BuzzFeed's latest fake news
embarrassment now naturally now that
bozos running in the Democratic primary
on against the Republican senator Cruz
no men's report in Reuters has been
published and its contents are downright
shocking as we continue to vet the
candidates on our Hannity watch
according to multiple outlets as a
teenager
O'Rourke helped found one of them
America's oldest hacking groups called
the cult of the dead cow and during his
time in the hacking community albedo and
his online friends stole video games
stole long-distance phone service for
his dial-up modem and engaged in various
other hacking efforts in the 1980s he
had the name psychedelic warlord and
bozo also frequently posted unusual
bizarre strange frightening writings on
group message boards including
classifying certain women as quote [ __ ]
ultra trendies are usually the scene
[ __ ] that many of the men folk admire
so and O'Rourke aka psychedelic warlord
wrote that the best way to deal with
these girls was to tell them that
they're ugly and a war COSO posted a
violent bizarre murder fantasy writing
quote one day as I was driving home from
work I noticed two children crossing the
street and as I neared the young ones I
put all of my weight on my right foot
keeping the accelerator pedal on
Flor until I heard the crashing of two
children on the hood and then the sharp
cry of pain from one of the two pretty
sick ugly twisted dark story goes from
there and it looked to be fair robert
francis was much younger at the time of
this disturbing publication but i asked
this question i wonder if the media the
left wonder if they'll follow the
Cavanagh standard from beta o'rourke
remember when they poured through
justice Kavanagh high school yearbook
all in an attempt to disqualify him from
the supreme court and that's not going
to happen with bado
or bozo in this case that is just their
standard for conservatives one standard
for liberals one standard for
conservatives in fact this report about
bado has barely made a dent in the
traditional news cycle still over the
weekend or Roark offered this heartfelt
apology take a look there was a report
they came out today then share things I
had written as a teenager
really April really bad stuff I'm
mortified to read it now
incredibly embarrassed but I have to
take ownership my words and understand
the way that they make people feel when
they read them now
wherever my intention was as as a
teenager it doesn't matter and so I
think I'll just speak for myself I have
to look long and hard at my actions and
the language that I have used and I have
to constantly try to do better
all right naturally in the
hypersensitive Democratic Party o'rourke
was also forced to issue several other
apologies including one a joke about his
wife raising their children and of
course his white privilege take a look
all right here we go yet another week
Democrats starting with apology tours
now more bad news for bozo the crowded
Democratic field is about to get even
bigger over the weekend former vice
president crazy uncle Joe Biden
accidentally announced his run for
president they took it back not uncommon
for him I know I get criticized
controlling it's criticized by the new
left I the most progressive record of
anybody running for the United wrong
you'd be
did anybody who would run in the same
day you can't work in my state the slave
state in a 7-eleven or a Dunkin Donuts
without a slight Indian accent and
refers to Barack Obama's Wow story book
he's clean and articulate whether or not
calf problem Biden actually runs for
president he's using his public status
much like the Clintons to rake in
millions from six figures speaking gigs
to seven figure book deals crazy Uncle
Joe is turning his humble public service
into a goldmine if he runs Biden would
be just the latest Democrat to engage in
class warfare politics all while sitting
on top of a mound of cash and the worst
record of any political team him and
Obama that we've seen in our lifetime
we're gonna have a lot more on 20/20
politics throughout the show and all
through the year but first we must turn
our attention to our important Hannity
watch on the deep state tonight we have
brand-new information we start with a
brand new USA Today Suffolk University
poll one half of Americans now believe
the president Trump is in fact a victim
of a witch hunt being carried out by
robert muller and his merry band of
democratic donors doesn't make take a
genius team of investigators to realize
that collusion is a hoax in fact
according to disgraced one time lead FBI
investigator Peter struck and his former
FBI lawyer
Lisa Paige they both said there was no
evidence of collusion when the special
counsel was appointed that's after they
investigated for nine straight months
before the appointment of Muller
here we are 670 days after the Muller
insensitive probe and intense as it's
been still no collusion none zero
nothing yeah it's a witch hunt and
meanwhile thanks to the newly released
depositions from ore and Paige and
struck and Steele and McCain associate
David Kramer
we have shocking new evidence tonight
detailing how a small group of
high-ranking bureaucrats how they tried
to use Hillary Clinton's phony bought
and paid for
Russian dossier to take down Donald
Trump we now know tonight that
Christopher Steele
gave the dirty dossier with Russian lies
to McCain associate David Kramer we know
tonight that Kramer sometimes that the
direction of Steel himself who hated
Donald Trump literally spread the
dossiers unverified uncorroborated
contents to 12 journalists at nine
different news outlets to State
Department officials including one
connected to John Kerry now why to use
the Hillary Clinton bought and paid for
Russian lies to influence you we the
people before the elections to influence
the outcome of that election and worse
and here's the bottom line according to
Bruce or Christopher Steele hated Donald
Trump was desperate to malign him as was
Hillary Clinton as was the upper echelon
at the FBI DOJ not rank-and-file as well
as the corrupt news media in this
country that just ran with these lies
never verified a thing it was
unverifiable because it wasn't true and
even though they all knew all were told
that this is unverified and corroborated
Hillary paid for it and still hated
Trump a pack of lies they tried to get
it salacious contents and they did out
to the general public
purposely lying propagandizing you we
the American people we have top DOJ and
FBI officials those are the same people
that saved Hillary Clinton from being
indicted something that would have
happened to all of us they worked on her
behalf
used her lies to commit fraud on FISA
courts spy on the Trump campaign even
before the election and after the
election and it's all now becoming
crystal clear tonight but this is only
the beginning what we now have is the
beginning of a cascade of information
and materials that will be corroborating
everything we have been telling you over
the last two years so tonight I can tell
you expect more damning revelations
about how the dossier was written where
its information was derived and how
high-ranking officials inside our
federal government abused their power to
help Hillary get elected and then later
to take down Donald Trump now we are on
the cusp of what is an avalanche of new
to